i talked to a woman recently who is an
activist but before she became
what she calls socially conscious she
says that for a long time she didn't
want to know about things that were
troubling other animals people in the
world
i think a lot of us have that view and
maybe through the blackfish that will
see that we can do things about
stuff that's not right in the world but
for those of us who are squeamish about
well i don't want to see that it's too
painful
what would you say you're part of voto
was it voice of the orcas
so what would you say to people who have
this sort of gnawing in their stomach
that something's not right about a
certain issue
whether it's animals people whatever and
they don't quite know how to take that
first step
to do something about it
i would say that we all went through
dealing with that challenge even as
trainers we talked about it a lot
amongst ourselves that there was a sort
of cognitive dissonance even there
because most of us really wanted to do
that job and we're very excited
to be doing that job and yet we saw
things that made us uncomfortable like
carol was saying
and so and so in order to stay in the
job we had to not look at things that
were actually happening or not really
think them through
and so i think everybody goes through
that process but i think ultimately
once you start seeing stuff if you don't
take the action
um you will it's going to keep gnawing
at you until you do something about it
and there's some simple steps that you
can do and we have them outlined on our
website at voice of the orcas
right i highly encourage people also to
go to the voice of the orcas and
um and take a look at the steps that are
outlined there for people who are ready
to kind of move on and and take some
steps that they're comfortable with
as far as making a difference
you